einer der großen momente gehst du wo man
ein stück top dogs markenwahrnehmung
nicht
[Musik]
und heilung sitzen sie erste mal beim
austreten und in der früh drauf und
china mit firma also mich würd's kühl
[Musik]
wir hoffen in justins kopf und das habe
mit einem gefechts diensten kombiniert
da haben wir die ganze staaten im
geschäft gemacht und noch haben wir zwar
gucken gemacht der nicht gesicherten
bereichs vorgerückt
[Musik]
es geht jetzt ist der mauer und von sich
gibt
[Musik]
allein mit ihrem freund der damals noch
recht zur bindung auf nummer
das ganze ist doch immer so gewiss
andere einstellung sind in sichtkontakt
herrscht ganz wichtig sonst so gut das
verhalten jan ehrung war absprache der
vorderste eigenen haus ganz gut gemacht
das merkt doch einmal fünf formationen
weil natürlich die gruppe jetzt die
ganzen informationen was führt sie vor
dem vor freunden ob das ganz wichtig das
weitere vorgehen als ob sehr gut macht
wirklich aufpassen dass die abstände
gleichbleibenden immer mit war vorne der
gruppen haben
ganz wichtig war das wäre sehr kultur
gibt jedes führungsfigur gehen
[Musik]
[Applaus]